Жодного дерева чи куща,
натомість сніг навіть улітку.
Провідник Ґеорґ Зіхельшмідт знає тут кожен камінь.
Це Халті, гірський масив на висоті тисяча триста метрів
на норвезько-фінському кордоні.
"Ми стоїмо на фінській частині Халті.
Ось праворуч прикордонний знак.
Це найвища точка Фінляндії.
Але якщо поглянути туди, то бачимо,
що там гора іще вища, і це вже Норвегія."
Фінам таке не дуже до вподоби.
У цій рівнинній країні, по суті, один гірський масив,
і то його вершина розташована на норвезькій території.
Дослідник норвезького картографічного інституту
Бйорн Гейрр Харссон вважає
що саме на часі виправити таку географічну несправедливість.
"Ми намагаємося переконати норвезький уряд
подарувати Фінляндії цю вершину до сторіччя незалежності."
Однодумець Харссона
бургомістр цього району Свейн Одвар Лейрос.
Саме він написав норвезькій прем'єр-міністерці
й отримав негативну відповідь.
Мовляв, конституція країни забороняє Норвегії роздаровувати свою землю.
Утім, прихильники такої ідеї переконані, що вихід є:
це обмін вершини на такий самий за розміром шматок фінської землі.
"Норвежці справді мають дуже багато інших гір,
на які вони можуть сходити.
А від цієї купи каміння, на якій ми стоїмо,
фіни навіть не мають верхівки.
Мені здається, це несправедливо: бідні фіни!"
Гірська вершина у подарунок стала би
прецедентом для цілого світу
символом територіального порозуміння.
"Норвегія щороку вручає Нобелівську премію миру.
І ми могли б показати добрий приклад у поводженні
із сусідами і віддати Фінляндії цей малесенький шматок землі."
Часу для такого широкого жесту залишається дедалі менше:
у грудні Фінляндія святкує сторіччя незалежності.
Можливо, все ж таки з новою найвищою точкою.